Madame Françoise Gatel vous avez la
parole pour le groupe Union centriste et
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission cher Valère il est tard
monsieur le rapporteur cher
Jean-Baptiste blanc cher collègue
disons-le clairement nul ne comptait la
nécessité de sobriété foncière à la fois
pour préserver notre agriculture mais
aussi notre environnement la preuve
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez
vous-même rappelé la diminution
significative de l'artificialisation
passée de 60 000 hectares environ 20 000
hectares depuis les années 2000 qui
atteste de la conscience et du sens de
la responsabilité des élus locaux mais
les dispositions actuelles de mise en
œuvre d'usane illustre parfaitement
comment une bonne intention peut se
transformer en absurdité voir en impasse
d'abord à cause de la pensée en silo que
nous adorons qui cultive à chaque fois
une bonne intention mais qui se
contredit
réindustrialisation oui logement oui
mais ânes non à cause de la dérive
réglementaire qui controvient à l'esprit
du législateur y a-t-il un meilleur
exemple que les décrets d'application du
zan à cause de la vacuité d'une étude
d'impact mise en évidence par le cnen à
cause de l'impensé de l'équilibre
territorial et du droit à l'Espérance et
à l'avenir de tous les territoires je
vous sais gré monsieur le ministre de
partager notre envie de sortir de cet
impact et de reconnaître la démarche
très constructive de la mission
sénatoriale conduite par nos collègues
Valérie l'État et Jean-Baptiste blanc
dont je tiens à saluer la qualité du
travail concrètement sur cette
proposition de loi je parlerai de deux
amendements évoquerez un souhait le
premier amendement porte sur la
nécessaire prise en compte de la
diversité de nos territoires et de la
libre administration des collectivités
en donnant droit à un accord local sur
la gouvernance du zinc le second
amendement porte sur l'exigence de
réactivité mais aussi de réalisme et
rappelle le danger de figer les choses
un instant T en permettant qu'un projet
d'intérêt général conforme aux enjeux
environnementaux ou de souveraineté et
qui apparaîtrait après la répartition
des droits initiales à
l'artificialisation puisse voir le jour
par le recours au pouvoir réglementaire
local du préfet auquel le Sénat tient
particulièrement après consultation de
l'instance de gouvernance régionale
d'usage et comme promis je conclurai par
un souhait puis sur nous tirer les
leçons du passé par une fabrique de la
loi moins hasardeuse et plus vertueuse
et qui met en son cœur l'étude d'impact
et l'évaluation c'est ce qui fera
l'objet des états généraux de la
simplification ce jeudi au Sénat auquel
nous aurons le grand plaisir de vous
accueillir monsieur le ministre comme
chacun peut le supputer ici le groupe
centriste votre a ce texte qui servira
tout à la fois la vertu et le bon sens
et puisque portalyse veille sur nous je
voudrais nous rappeler collectivement
que la loi est faite pour les hommes les
femmes aussi naturellement mais en tout
cas les hommes et les femmes doivent
être entendues et eux ne sont pas fait
forcément pour des lois qui sont un peu
mal faites je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur